a rare piece of good news amongst the
coronavirus misery
bolivia's first vaccination a nurse in
the country's hearted eastern city of
santa cruz
i feel good very excited and also a bit
nervous
but positive she's in the front line
doctors warner medic is dying every day
the virus has killed 10 000 bolivians
the government has ordered 15 million
more doses of the russian smutnik and
the oxford astrosenica vaccines
we have a plan to combat the coronavirus
in this second wave a plan that has
stages such as tests
tests and more tests a plan that has a
second element the provision of vaccines
that today are becoming a reality for
our health workers
there's a similar story in colombia
where the president announced the
national vaccination program
is to begin in three weeks
i would like to inform colombians that
at this moment acquisitions are
completely closed
in order to guarantee the vaccination
for the target population that we set
out in the national vaccination plan
a new lockdown has been imposed in the
capital bogota
while borders remain closed trapping
these migrants
mostly from haiti but also cuba and
africa
their ultimate destination is the united
states
la petition the request they have made
is to be allowed entry into panama
that is not possible because there is a
presidential order to close the borders
as a precautionary measure but in
addition panama has all of its borders
closed
guyana has closed its long border with
brazil barbados has announced a lockdown
while canada has closed air traffic from
the caribbean and mexico
until april in mexico the president went
before the cameras
to say he's recovering from the virus
and to announce the purchase of maxine's
i still have coveted but the doctors
tell me that i have passed the critical
phase
i am now presenting myself to you so
that there are no rumors or
misunderstandings
i am well although i still have to rest
he was speaking as mexico became the
country in the world
with the third highest number of
coronavirus deaths
more than 155 000 behind only the us and
brazil
a situation made worse by oxidant
shortages in the capital
despite that foreign tourists taking
advantage of mexico's more relaxed
travel restrictions
continue to flock to the beaches the
coronavirus
uh some of us in our family have already
had it
it's not that big a deal and the
governments are making it worse than it
actually is
however for many elsewhere in latin
america it can't get much worse
the vaccination programs provide hope
but on a horizon that's still a long way
off
daniel schweiner al-jazeera buenos aires